près de 400 personnes ont rendu ce matin
un dernier hommage d'un philippe léotard
décédé samedi dernier
les obsèques du comédien se sont
déroulées au cimetière du père lachaise
à paris en présence de nombreuses
personnalités
christophe medard et bruno livertout no
majo poète aux clowns ou saltimbanques
de nombreuses personnalités se sont
pressés dans la petite chapelle du père
lachaise pour saluer la mémoire de
philippe léotard en tête du cortège
son frère cadet françois revenu exprès
de macédoine
patrice chéreau et claude lelouch des
metteurs en scène qui ont tournés avec
le comédien mais aussi des hommes
politiques
les anciens ministres gérard longuet et
françois bayrou
tous ceux qui l'ont rencontré deux
disent que m
non c'est non
lance une immense sensibilité et par
dessus tout c'est à cause de tout cela
beaucoup de confiance
la cérémonie s'est ouverte et achevée
avec des chants corses un souhait sans
doute de sa mère née sur l'île de beauté
faute de place les nombreux anonymes
venus témoigner leur sympathie se sont
réunis à l'extérieur de la chapelle
j'adorais l'artiste poète le chanteur
s'était surtout l'homme mais c'était
c'est un écorché vif
c'est un amoureux dans tous les sens du
terme
il était formidable à la scène et peu de
gens me disent mais c'était d'arrêter
une force à la brède huard et j'aime et
je trouve que c'est quelqu'un qui va
nous manquer vite et on va s'entendre on
va commencer à le connaître je crois
ensuite un long cortège a suivi la
dépouille mortelle au crématorium du
père lachaise
l'occasion aussi d'écrire quelques
lignes en hommage à cet acteur poète au
corps tendre